Speaker 1: Uh, today we have with us Abhas Srivastava, Assistant Professor of Public Law at Sharda Law School at Sharda University. Abhas, thank you so much for joining us today for this conversation.
Speaker 2: It's a pleasure.
Speaker 1: Yes. Uh, so, uh, today Abhas and I will be focusing on some meaningful interventions vis-a-vis renting in India. So Abhas, based on that my first question is, if a landlord refuses to rent to someone because they are unmarried, queer, or from a minority community, is there any constitutional ground a tenant can actually stand on or does the constitution simply not reach
Speaker 1: such private transactions. How do you actually do this in practice?
Speaker 2: See, constitution does have grounds, right, which may be invoked in certain situations and occasions. I would say that these are very flimsy grounds, right, not very well developed in India. Neither they are invoked, neither they are, you know, records by the authorities as well, right? And and one more thing, forget about renting, even in India if you want to go and stay in a hotel, right, then also your identity, whether you are married or you are, you know, what kind of sexuality you have, all these factors are very important.
Speaker 2: important just to get a hotel room for a couple of nights also, right? So considering a year long or a six years long rent agreement, right? It is much bigger a deal, right? So so far as our constitution is concerned, the Indian constitution is concerned, right? There are few provisions and there are few, you know, ideologies that come to the rescue of those who have been victimized by this discriminatory treatment. So firstly, if we look at article 15 of the constitution, right? It talks about talks about certain
Speaker 2: equalities and discriminations in private transactions, right? So Article 15 categorically mentions that people cannot be denied access to certain kind of public and private properties, right? And in that sense, Article 15 is a ground which covers discrimination done by private individuals, right? Now this discrimination as per the wordings of Article 15 is based on religion, race, caste, sex or any of them or basically place of birth, right? So if a tenant is discriminated on these grounds,
Speaker 2: which are mentioned in 15. So under that scope and under that provision there is a scope, right? And few high courts have reinstated also that you know, such kind of transactions where categorically based on are your identity if you are disallowed access or disallowed to exercise those rights which you possess under the law. That would be actionable under the writ jurisdiction of High Court and Supreme Court under Article 226 and 32 of the Constitution. So that stands to be the first ground. Secondly, in India the social structure has a caste composition.
Speaker 2: that we are aware of. So if caste becomes a criteria of denying the, you know, tenancy, then of course under the protection of civil rights act, there is a wholesome mechanism backed by article 17 of the constitution to institute action, right? Apart from that, there is one another provision which I would like to just discuss, which is in regards to, you know, the rights which have evolved, you know, in last couple of years. So article 21 and 19 have now been expanded a lot.
Speaker 2: by the judiciary in India. So where basically the freedom of movement, freedom to settle in India and then freedom of the the the the right of dignity and right of livelihood, right of shelter, all these rights have been identified. Now if we, you know, do a co-joint reading of all these rights, right? Then under the writ jurisdiction of courts, the tenants can definitely take over, you know, actions, right? So in sense the rights framework is existing, but it is less resorted to. I have just managed to get some statistics.
Speaker 2: districts also. Till now in India, you know, you would be surprised to know that only 700 cases have been instituted by tenants who have been, you know, wrongfully either evicted based on these exclusions or they have been denied a rental property. They have been denied admission to a rental property and this data is of last 3 years, right? So you can consider the nature of, you know, reports to legal institutions in this regard.
Speaker 1: Okay
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah. Um, definitely like, uh, this is a real problem in our society that unfortunately no one addresses. The common retort that is given is that, oh, it's the landlord's house. They can do whatever they want. They can deny anybody on any grounds and it's okay, and then they can do whatever they want with the tenant after that also. So, which, which seems absurd to me considering we have so many constitutional and legal provisions in place.
Speaker 2: They can do
Speaker 2: Okay
Speaker 2: Yes
Speaker 1: Yeah. And could you tell us about any Supreme Court judgments or any court judgments around Article 21 and the right to shelter that have shaped tenant rights or perhaps an ongoing case that could bring meaningful change in this regard?
Speaker 2: Yeah, uh, there is, there has been a case, see, there has been a transitional shift in this issue, right? So far as the renting is concerned, directly courts have not identified this area as a subject matter of rights, right? But over a period of time it has developed. So initially it began with the Olga Delis case where the refugees of a natural disaster, right? They were forcefully evicted by, uh, by the Bombay Municipal Corporation. They were occupying public land.
Speaker 2: So courts have came to their rescue that you simply cannot do that. Then the Chameli's case that you might be aware of is a landmark judgment in this regard. Then from from Ahmedabad Municipal Corporation versus Nawab Khan's case, that is another judgment in which court has identified that people who are living on footpaths or they have occupied slums, right? area has been you know developed over a period of time as slums because people do not have shelter. Those people definitely have a right to stay there, right? Now
Speaker 2: Now, all these judgments surprisingly have identified or given legal protection to only people in distress, right? If you are victim of a natural disaster, if you are a person who cannot afford housing and you're occupying a slum, or if you are a victim of some of organized crime, then these rights were basically been protected, right? But a shift came in the approach of the court with two very popular movements in India. First was the recognition of the third gender and the debate around arguing for rights over them.
Speaker 2: And then the third was the the recent changes in the property law regime, right? Where housing societies were given recognition and they were given state approval, right? So now these two movements have contributed in sense of you know, developing a you know, framework for tenants, right? Where prospective tenants I will say, where people would be allowed tenancy or they would basically not be disallowed tenancy based upon the preconceived grounds of discrimination, right? So
Speaker 2: A very recent case that I could come across in this regard, I'll just, you know, tell you the name.
Speaker 1: But
Speaker 2: in which has basically covered the private transactions on on these time. So there is a case come from 2023 Kaushal Kishore versus State of Uttar Pradesh, right? Now this particular case has in the Supreme Court has recognized that a person, right, who is looking for a tenancy in any part of the country, right? He has to be treated with dignity. His identity is not the criteria based on which the tenancy agreement would be determined. His ability to afford that housing is the bank.
Speaker 2: memory criteria, right? So the court has given an economic criteria rather than a social or political identity criteria which perhaps till now has been excluding a major chunk of people. Now very recently if you see then there have been there have been few associations in India in LGBTQ marriages. Marriages are not recognized as of now but then associations are recognized. So the LGBTQ couples, queer couples or maybe gay couples or lesbian couples, they have been you know trying
Speaker 2: to rent the houses whereby they have declared in advance that they are of this particular category, right? And surprisingly certain cosmopolitan cities in India like Mumbai and Delhi, right? People have raised no objection about these issues. The only thing that mattered to them that was that you please comply with the societal norms, the norms of the housing society. Don't create any nuisance, right? Just follow these rules and we are happy to give you the housing despite your identity which till now was considered as taboo in India, right? So,
Speaker 2: I would just like to reiterate that at a social level, the mindset is shifting, right? And at the level of judiciary, right? The court has now identified that this is perhaps an area where a positive intervention is required, where a linkage between this exclusion and the right under article under part three of the constitution is required, right? So therefore the courts are now evolving this tenancy rights as a separate jurisprudence altogether.
Speaker 1: Hmm
Speaker 1: minute
Speaker 1: Okay, okay, that's that's quite insightful. And, um, coming to the next question, the constitution guarantees us certain rights, uh, such as of course to shelter and to privacy. But when a landlord is moral policing you or harassing you, you know, being bigoted in the moment, you know, while you're trying to rent with them, uh, quoting constitutional provisions that them will most likely not help. They will be like, I don't care, this is my house, you can go and find another accommodation. So,
Speaker 1: or you know, even if they have given the house to somebody on rent, the tenant tries to say that, you know, I know my rights, I know the law. Most likely, it will not affect the landlord in any way, threaten him in any way. So how does a tenant actually exercise these rights in practice? How do you like really because a lot of people I spoke to in interviews said that, you know,
Speaker 2: Privacy
Speaker 2: Okay
Speaker 1: I know my rights or maybe, you know, maybe I don't, but how would knowing my rights help me in these real-world situations? Correct. Yeah.
Speaker 2: Correct. That is a very pertinent and particular question, right? And because you know, when things turn out, when you are actually facing the heat, right? And if you start jabbing that you have these rights, right? Then the other person simply doesn't care, right? So this is something which every tenant will face even if even if they have everything proper, they are heterosexual couples, right? They are of the legal age, they are complying with all the norms, they are belonging to the particular domain.
Speaker 2: you know, segment of the society where perhaps they have a social standing also. Then also if the landlord landlord wants, right, he can evict people at any point of time, right? And then also he they that segment of people might not get a, you know, apartment for rent, right? So consider about those, you know, marginalized categories, right? So of course the problem is actually a real time problem with no solutions, I'll say, right? Unfortunately, I have to put it like this that there are
Speaker 2: very little resources in these kind of situations and there are there are a few reasons for that I'll tell you. You we we know that India has you know transition from you know kind of agrarian to industrial economy, right? And in India we do believe in socialism not only we as citizens but our constitution entails that socialism has to be the norm, right? Now when capitalism hit our country the property rights framework got strong, right? And somehow we have a
Speaker 2: you know, parental approach towards the property, like we protect our parents, right? In India, people protect their property likewise. And at the same time, you know, when we talk about property, right, the right of exclusive use and alienation, right? All these rights are very much rigidly imbibed into the heads of individuals in India, right? So they consider that a property is something over which they have their exclusive right. They will decide who will occupy it, who will not and all such things. So that legal mindset is also existing, right?
Speaker 2: Second thing is this that the amount of time which is taken by the court system in India to adjudicate disputes or to entertain disputes, right, is way too high. If I am a prospective tenant and I come across a landlord who has, you know, just said that I don't want to give you apartment because you belong to X community, right, instead of arguing with him, showing him what rights I have and approaching the, you know, rent rent dispute forums, right, or
Speaker 2: going to a court for filing cases. I'll simply prefer that I'll go move and find the next option, right? So now this this motivation to find the next option compared to enforcing my right is because as a litigant I know that for such issues if I'm going to court I'll be wasting my time, right? And at the end perhaps I'll be getting peanuts only, right? So that that you know possible outcome of a proceeding is visible to people in India, right? But one thing is definitely there even though people may
Speaker 2: not have a direct access to courts in this regard or even if there are access then they are not enjoying it that is you know problem of the settled psychology of people but then you might not have a direct recourse to these kind of denials but you have a recourse to the consequences right if I am occupying somebody's flat I'm a tenant and then the landlord enters without my permission right under the criminal law and tortuous framework also I have the right to sue my landlord right Indian courts have allowed those
Speaker 2: cases even in the property in the property act sorry the transfer of property act also mentions that advance notice has to be given by the 10 landlord before he enters into the premises right. Not only this.
Speaker 1: Yeah
Speaker 2: If that landlord enters into the premise which I am occupying or which I am a tenant and he creates any kind of disturbances there, I may go, you know, invoke the criminal law. So I may file a complaint or FIR for criminal trespass or maybe criminal nuisance or I can go for criminal intimidation, assault, battery, whatever. So I can invoke that particular framework. If the person occupying the premise is a female, right, then definitely all the laws which are made for protective discrimination.
Speaker 2: of the females that would be applicable, right? Which means to say that the landlord has to respect the modesty of that female. If he's doing something, he's saying some words, gestures, etcetera, which indicate outraging the modesty, then that particular female who is a tenant in that house has the option to file cases. Not only this, right? If the eviction is arbitrary or is not as per the or is not in tune with the rental agreement, then there is a rent tribunal also in every district that
Speaker 2: tribunal is constituted in India. So you can go and file a case challenging the eviction and the tribunals in India have been good decent enough to, you know, kind of order reinstatement of the tenants also, right? So there are these two three mechanisms which protect the ancillary rights in regards to tenancy, not the act of tenancy per se, right? But if you're a tenant, such things are applicable, but if you're a prospective tenant, right? Then of course nothing is applicable to you, right?
Speaker 2: The origin of the right or the conception of the right is from the moment when the tenancy begins. Then you definitely have some rights which you can enforce through courts and enforcement agencies. But if you are a prospective tenant, then as I mentioned in the previous question, very few rights you have, right?
Speaker 1: is applicable
Speaker 1: Right so that
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, it makes a lot of sense. Sad but very true in the context of urban India, I would say. And I mean, do you think recording such interactions using social media perhaps would help?
Speaker 2: Yeah
Speaker 2: Uh, if if you, yeah, they they help for two reasons I'll say they help, right? Because if you later choose to institute a proceeding, uh, formal legal proceeding, right? They would be admissible as evidence and they'll be, you know, beneficial for the tenants, right? That they can easily establish their cases because, you know, in case in rental agreements because, you know, private transaction is happening, right? There are no witnesses across that they have seeing what is happening or what is not happening. So such kind of conversations or such recordings, video audios are relevant for the people, right?
Speaker 2: who want to enforce their right. And not only this, the recordings are also relevant from this point of view that I'll tell you that such kind of incidents, right, compel the local administration to act, right? Very recently there was a reel that got very viral in India, right? A particular female who was adult was occupying a premises and over the weekend he invite she invited her boyfriend, right? And at that moment uninformed the landlord enters. She is also a lady.
Speaker 2: Right? She sees there is a boy, right? And then she starts scolding and everything. Then that female, that the tenant female, she recorded the entire conversation and put her on the social media. Now the social media in which, you know, many people were in favor of that tenant, right? They wanted that the privacy should be protected. They wanted that if I am occupying a tenancy or I am occupying some premises, I should be allowed to call over my friends, call over my relatives for overnight, right? Because that is the part of the possession, right? Possession definitely means
Speaker 2: Even though possession is a limited enjoyment of that property, but within that limited enjoyment, I do have the right to call people who with whom I have any kind of acquaintances, right? So that particular situations definitely create a pressure on the local administration to act and then to kind of ensure at a local level that such things are not repeated. Very common problem I'll tell you is that unmarried these bachelors are not, bachelor males are not getting flats, right? This is something which is very common you'll find in every city in India. Now, urban cities this problem has now reduced, right?
Speaker 2: for a very simple reason that because of the social media movements, because of the people going to police for complaining that see, we are facing this kind of problems, where should we go, right? And the local immigration officer, local this migration officer has to intervene and then they have to ensure that they have to convince the housing societies that you should not simply disallow this. So all these things definitely create a kind of movement in which these rights could be developed and from the evidence point of view and the, you know, these judicial point of view.
Speaker 2: they create a strong evidence backing which definitely entail the litigant to a particular remedy.
Speaker 1: These rights could be
Speaker 1: Makes makes sense, makes sense. And, um, coming to legal remedies, you know, building upon that. Uh, could you tell us, uh, perhaps about some lesser known NGOs or legal groups that can help marginalized renters in such situations on maybe a pro bono basis or like, uh, low cost?
Speaker 2: See, to be honest, there are very little NGOs or the self-help groups which are dedicatedly working on this issue, right? Few have been taken up. Few NGOs are there who have taken up this issue. But then again, they are working for people who have marginal, who are either marginalized or who face discrimination in private spheres, right? So there is this University Jindal Global University, they have a very dedicated and well-functioning center, right?
Speaker 2: within their university premises which is basically center for justice, law and society, right? It is working on the issues of marginalized, right? So a good friend of mine is heading the center there. So she did mention that they are taking up cases of this kind of discriminations, right? Either wrongful expulsion of the tenants or people being denied these housing rights because housing rights are now part of statutory as well as constitutional framework. So as private individuals we simply cannot just close
Speaker 2: to bang the door against their faces, right? So this is the one area, one, you know, group I know in Bangalore, since in Bangalore, Bengaluru, this issue is, is, was a very severe issue 5, 7 years back. So there two NGOs have become very, very popular. One is alternative law forum, right? If you, if you go to their even websites, the success stories simply indicate that they have ensured that more than, you know, 54000 individuals, right? From 2017 they are functioning.
Speaker 2: Right and it ensure that these many individuals do get access to housing and they are also dedicated for the cause of LGBTQ, right? So they are ensuring that they also by displaying their identity in open they also are not denied these kind of housing rights. Then there is one another NGO which is working which under the banner of I pro bono India, right? So now the this NGO has presence in four five cities in India which is again looking after these kind of issues, right?
Speaker 2: people who are struggling into you know getting these housing housing affordability issues or issues of having housing, right? Despite their economic competence to do so, right? So this NGO is also working, right? So the most of the NGOs are working on convincing and negotiation models. Very few are taking the cases to the court until and unless there are blatant violation of rights, right? But then they try to sit and they try to mediate the issues on the problems which these
Speaker 2: you know, prospective trend and surfacing.
Speaker 1: Okay, okay. And, um, I will also go back to the question I asked you before this, based on that. Uh, RWAs create a lot of problems for tenants generally. And many of them exercise bizarre rules or issue bizarre dictats. And, you know, sometimes compelling tenants to leave mid tenancy, you know, if they just crowd in front of your door, uh, a bunch of neighborhood uncles with a lot of cloud and cloud.
Speaker 1: and power. What can you possibly do in that situation? You will prioritize your peace of mind and you might just be pushed out of that location very soon. You'll go find houses somewhere else. So if you could also tell us a little bit about RWAs, what rights they actually have, what rights they don't have and maybe what tenants can do in these situations as well.
Speaker 2: Hmm
Speaker 2: Right. So most of these, you know, resident welfare associations that we basically refer.
Speaker 2: First of all, we have to understand that whether they carry any legal identity or not, right? So they are associations of persons, AOPs, right? Few of them are not even registered. In fact, many of them are not even registered. They were voluntarily, you know, using association name. If they are registered, right, they have limited right of maintaining the infrastructure of the society or that, you know, premises. Second right which they have is to ensure that the tenancy.
Speaker 2: the tenants, right? They are complying with the norms laid down by either the parent housing act or by the governing committee of that particular society, right? Now, in order to do that, what their model is very clear, they will try to create immediate pressure on the tenants, right? For whatsoever they feel is not as per the standard, right? Not only the tenants, they will also compel the landlord, right? That you please ask your tenant to vacate. So from both sides, you know, this
Speaker 2: issues will come. Second, what they will ensure is that essential supplies to that particular dwelling units are cut. So they will try to ensure that though no electricity is there or Wi-Fi is not working at your place, they will even ask the domestic workers not to report to your houses, right? Then all such kind of issues they keep on creating, right? So their model is only to create a pressure because they know that without a formal written notice,
Speaker 2: Right, without giving the tenants the time which is agreed in the rental agreement, right, to vacate. And the grounds which are agreed to vacate, they simply cannot evict any person. So their model is very clear, they want to create a pressure. Now, as a tenant, what should we do, right? First of all, the first extra legal step is to take your owner into the confidence, take the landlord into the confidence that see, I have not done anything wrong. Just give me time to sort this issue. Second thing that you have to do is that you have to first approach the local police station and you have to file a
Speaker 2: complaint, right? Addressing this issue that I have been, I am being troubled by my neighbors, right? For something which I have not done. Then you have to go to the rent tribunal, right? Right. Immediate remedy is to go to the rent tribunal where you can file a suit of anti-eviction suit, you can file or you can file an application for interim stay, right? So whereby the rent agreement will assume jurisdiction and they will look into your complaint individually that what wrong has been done. Now,
Speaker 2: This is the first thing that you can these are the first few steps that you have to follow. Once the matter goes to the rents tribunal, right? Then the administering body of that particular society or dwelling unit is responsible to respond, right? And if you get a early injunction order or a early stay order, right? The status quo will remain intact. Matlab if you are occupying the tenancy, you will be allowed to occupy till the matter is being disposed of. Parallelly you can approach the civil court, right? To file other kinds of
Speaker 2: themes of violation of civil rights and compensation, right? Now, all these the the the last step may be excluded, right? It may be excluded because it's a long-term process, but these rent approaching the rent tribunal is something that you must immediately do. The rent agreement, this rental laws in India do provide tenants a particular set of remedies. So few of them are the permanent remedies, few are immediate or interim remedies and the under the act
Speaker 2: A 30-day timeline has also been specified to dispose of a petition or application which is filed for seeking any interim remedy, right? Most of the tenants, they succumb to this pressure, right? Even the landlord also doesn't want that any police should come or they should be, you know, highlighted because that affects their prospectivity in terms of having another tenant, right? So they will also try to discourage you, they will also say okay, we will wave off the notice requirement, okay, we will return all your
Speaker 2: of security immediately, but you please vacate, right? So that informality immediately steps into, right? Nobody wants to be into that trouble and therefore all these issues keep on reinstating because nobody has ever taken a strong legal stand and wherever these stands have been taken, right? The tenants definitely have got not only the reinstatement, they have been reinstated back into the property, but they have received compensation also from these RWAs, right? For wrongfully causing annoyance and nuisance in the private space of these individuals.
Speaker 2: Right? So, ours the only task which I would recommend is that you have to first just take a firm stand. You have to ask, you have to approach the authorities, right? Don't succumb to the pressure because that is the only model in which RWAs are operating across India.
Speaker 1: Okay, thank you, thank you. That really is quite insightful. And that brings me to my last question. If you could change one thing about how tenancy laws work in India to better protect vulnerable renters, what would it be?
Speaker 2: Vulnerable genders.
Speaker 1: Renters
Speaker 2: renters, okay. Okay, so first thing which I would recommend is that there should be a model tenancy act which should be applicable across India, right? So there has to be a proper law because till now it is a state subject falling under the state list. So states, you know, the regime is changing from state to state, right? So a model tenancy act should be there. Now why I'm saying it should be a pan India law is because the right to rent is
Speaker 2: a right coming from Article 19, right, to settle in any part of the country, which is a pan India right available to us. So there should be a pan India remedy which should be available. So that goes in tune with that framework. So, and that law should definitely have two things, right? Firstly, it should have a strong non-discrimination remedies framework, right? It should that law should define that what amounts to discrimination in terms of tenancy, right? Discrimination not in the popular sense of Article 14 of our
Speaker 2: constitution for discrimination in sense of these private transactions. See, I'll give you example, right? Under Indian property transfer framework, right? If you are belonging to SC or ST community, right? You simply a person belong not belonging to these communities cannot purchase the land directly from these communities, right? If I belong to a general community and I have to purchase a land which belongs to SC, ST, OBC group, I simply cannot purchase the land. They can simply cannot sell it because that transaction would be viewed with suspicion.
Speaker 2: So I have to take the permission of the local SDM and Tehsildar that I want to purchase this SC land. Kindly allow me, there is no influence, there is no undue advantage which I'm taking. All such declarations I have to give, right? So likewise, since see that law defines, you know, that puts a restriction on land transfer, right? Identifying a issue. So that law defines restriction on land transfer in this context. Likewise, the model tenancy law which I think should
Speaker 2: should be there, should have strong definitions as to what amounts of discrimination in
Speaker 2: Renting ya the premises also during the time that tenancy is in operation, right? So what kind of discriminations are there? Second thing is this that there should be a, you know, dedicated grievance officer, right? Who should be appointed for these kind of issues. I'll tell you under so many laws we have either probationary officer, we have a maintenance officer also, right? We have a juvenile officer also, right? So many officers are there and under different different statutes.
Speaker 2: C laws, sorry, the total rent agreements that happen in India, right, are approximately ₹1.7 crores, right, in a particular year. Now you can understand how many people actually rent in India, right? This is the figure which I am giving you. So for these kind, for these sect of population, there should be a dedicated officer at district level. He may not be separately appointed, he may be a nominated one who should listen to the grievance because, you know, directly recoursing to judicial remedy.
Speaker 2: is something which I am not a personal fan of. There should be administrative adjudication. There should be administrative machinery which can resolve your, which should resolve your dispute, right? So that thing should be there. Thirdly, I want to say the unregulated area is these RWAs which you mentioned or the operative societies, right? They, there should be a framework of do's and don'ts that should be prescribed either under the existing framework or in this model tenancy law that what rights do they have and there should be a
Speaker 2: Due process should be prescribed for them as I told you. Due process is totally missing in the entire tenancy, you know, laws in India, right? Nobody sends a notice, nobody is giving you the time to vacate. There is no free transit, there is no free time which is given you to vacate. There is no proper, you know, you know, there are, you know, see, they even cut your supplies as I mentioned, right? So all these things are very, very, you know, anti-human treatment, I'll say. They compromise with the dignity of those particular individuals. So the due diligence and due due process framework.
Speaker 2: Teamwork for these people, for these RWAs should definitely be there, right? So these three, four things if they are done, most of the problems, I will say 70, 80% problems which tenants are facing in India, they would automatically be solved.
Speaker 1: Definitely, definitely. Thank you so much for this conversation Abhas and I really think that the the community of marginalized renters in urban Indian spaces might benefit from this. At least that's what I hope for. Thank you so much for joining Rent Without Fear. Thank you so much.